Constantine Kissen of Trigonometry fame
asks a very simple but important
question. Is Islam a religion of peace?
And I was impressed by his answer. I've
been responding to this question for
more than two decades now. And I can say
that Constantine Kissen has something
very very relevant to add especially for
those of us in the West and especially
for our leaders. Let's go through some
of this. Constantine begins by framing
the issue in terms of mass immigration.
The rise of anti-immigration parties
across Europe is not a response to mass
immigration, per se. It's a response to
the importation of large numbers of
people from what even the bravest of our
politicians euphemistically call
incompatible cultures. To them, the
problem is not immigration, it's Islam.
So, anti-immigration parties are popping
up all over Europe, but the real issue
isn't immigration. It seems to be Islam.
Constantine goes on to point out that in
Europe, there are tons of immigrants
from countries around the world. And
yet, there isn't much hostility towards
most immigrants from various countries
because they're not causing problems.
Problems seem to come from one
particular source. So what are the
different ways of addressing this issue?
There are three broad schools of thought
on this issue. The progressive response
is the head in the sand mantra of
diversity is our greatest strength. The
slogan mindlessly repeated is a proxy
for a whole host of dishonesties. And
now he goes through the progressive ways
of responding to the problem. First and
for as long as possible they will
pretend that there is no problem. When
Islamist terrorism is discussed, they
will immediately try to contextualize
the debate by talking about far-right
violence and other threats. So if you
complain about jihad, they will
instantly point to the dangers of the
far right. But that's simply dishonest
because statistics show where the
problem lies. 75% of MI5's case load
involves Islamist terrorism, with over
90% of the 43,000 people on MI5's terror
watch list being Islamist extremists. If
Islam isn't the problem, how do you
explain these numbers? To understand
this in its actual context, consider
that only 6% of people in Britain are
Muslim. In other words, Islamist
extremism is not only a huge problem,
it's a disproportionately huge problem.
Muslims are a small percentage of the
British population, but a huge
percentage of the people on terror watch
lists. Why is that coincidence?
Second, once people who hold this view
are forced to confront some measure of
reality and accept the problem exists,
they will pivot to blaming causes like
poverty, discrimination, alienation, and
so on. They will ignore the fact that
other groups in our society suffer from
these problems and do not engage in
terrorism, mass rape, gangs, or
sectarian violence. Did you catch that?
When confronted with statistics,
progressives will blame something else
for the correlation. It's because of
poverty or discrimination, but other
groups face poverty and discrimination.
Why aren't these other groups massively
over represented on terror watch lists?
Third, they will immediately accuse
anyone who attempts to look for
solutions of being racist, Islamophobic,
and so on. Yes, when all else fails,
just call people racists, bigots, and
Islamophobes.
This package of lies combined with the
reality of the problem itself has given
rise to the second and in some ways
equal and opposite school of thought.
According to this perspective, the
problem is not Islamism. It's Islam
itself. This would be my perspective.
Islam is the problem because Islam's
most trusted sources are filled with
commands and claims that lead to the
problems we see. For example, Surah
5:51. Oh you who believe, take not the
Jews and the Christians as aliyah,
friends, protectors, helpers. They are
but aliyah of each other. And if any
amongst you takes them as aliyah, then
surely he is one of them. Verily Allah
guides not those people who are the
zalamoon, polytheists and wrongdoers and
unjust. So don't take Jews or Christians
as friends, protectors, or helpers. If
you do, you're a Jew or a Christian, not
a Muslim. Surah
9:29 fight against those who believe not
in Allah nor in the last day nor forbid
that which has been forbidden by Allah
and his messenger Muhammad and those who
acknowledge not the religion of truth
i.e Islam among the people of the
scripture Jews and Christians until they
pay the jiza with willing submission and
feel themselves subdued. So Allah
commands his followers to fight us until
we pay tribute money called jiza with
willing submission and feel ourselves
subdued. What's jiza? Here's the
commentary. Paying jiza is a sign of
kufur unbelief and disgrace. Allah said
until they pay the Jiza, if they do not
choose to embrace Islam with willing
submission in defeat and subservience
and feel themselves subdued, disgraced,
humiliated, and belittled. One more
surah 98:6.
Verily those who disbelieve in the
religion of Islam, the Quran and Prophet
Muhammad from among the people of the
scripture, Jews and Christians and al-
Mushrakun. Mushrakun are people who
associate partners with Allah will abide
in the fire of hell. They are the worst
of creatures. According to the Quran,
Jews and Christians are the worst of
creatures. We're lower than dogs. We're
lower than pigs. We're lower than
insects.
There are tons of passages like these in
the Quran and the Hadith. Doesn't mean
there aren't plenty of Muslims who
ignore them or reinterpret them. But
there are plenty of Muslims who don't
ignore them or reinterpret them. And
that's a problem to this camp. The fact
that most Muslims are decent, peaceful
people is irrelevant because to this
view, they are so in spite of the
teachings of their religion. In other
words, lots of Muslims not following
violent commands of the Quran doesn't
mean these violent commands of the Quran
aren't a problem, especially when there
are Muslims who do follow these violent
commands of the Quran. So, it makes
sense to point to Islam as the problem.
But Constantine has an objection to this
reasoning. The problem I've always had
with this argument though is that there
are many countries around the world
which are majority Muslim and some with
large Muslim minorities like Singapore
which appear to have dealt with Islamist
extremism far better than we have in
Western Europe. There are Muslim
majority countries that don't have the
terror attacks or the grooming gangs or
the other issues we're facing. So if
Islam is the problem, why isn't Islam
the problem in these other countries?
This leads Constantine to the third
perspective. Again, the first
perspective is that there is no problem
with Islam. The second perspective is
that Islam is the problem. But there's a
third perspective. While remaining
open-minded to different perspectives
and claiming no expertise, I lean
towards the third camp. People who
believe that religious extremism is a
problem which has a tried and tested
solution. Religious extremism is a
problem, but there's a tried and tested
solution. This perspective doesn't deny
that the teachings of the Quran are a
problem. It simply points out that other
nations have shown how to deal with the
problem, which means that if Western
nations have the problem, it's because
they're not dealing with the problem the
way other nations have. And Constantine
focuses primarily on Usuzbekiststan
because he used to live there. Almost
95% of the people of Usuzbekiststan are
Muslims, but there's very little Islamic
extremism. You don't see many women in
burkas. Women wear jeans. You can buy
alcohol. Jihadis aren't running around
trying to subjugate the non-Muslims.
If Islam is the problem, why isn't it
such a big problem in Usuzbekiststan or
in certain other countries with Muslim
majority
populations? Constantine offers an
answer, and I think he's right. There is
no serious problem with radical Islam
here because the people in charge
understand the threat and are prepared
to deal with it. The reason Islam isn't
a serious threat in places like
Usuzbekiststan is that the leaders
understand the threat and are prepared
to deal with it. If you start calling
for jihad in your mosque, the leaders
are going to make you stop. If you start
some grooming gangs, the leaders are
going to crush you. If you try to impose
the burka on women, the leaders aren't
going to let you.
That's the difference between places
like Usuzbekiststan and places like the
UK. In the UK, leaders don't understand
the problem and they're not prepared to
deal with it. Islamists thrive in an
atmosphere of ignorance and cowardice.
They don't thrive where leaders
recognize the problem and aren't afraid
to deal with it. So the problem in
Western nations that can't seem to stop
the Islamists isn't just the Islamists.
The problem is that the Islamists are
free to run wild due to ignorance and
cowardice. And I think we can all agree
that Constantine is right. Before we
close out, I just want to add that part
of the reason places like Usbekistsan
have leaders who understand the threat
and are willing to deal with it is that
they have a strong culture. A strong
culture isn't going to look the other
way when a threat emerges. Western
nations used to have a strong culture.
People were willing to stand up for what
they believed in. Then we were all
taught to despise our own culture. This
led to weak leaders who think we're so
bad we deserve to be subjugated. And
once your society absorbs that idea, you
are doomed unless you change it. This is
one of the reasons I've been promoting
arts for the past few months, believe it
or not, some people in some places guard
their traditions. They value them.
They're not ashamed of them. They fight
for them. They want to share their
traditions with others. They dedicate
their lives to preserving their values
and their traditions and their culture.
And that's why their values and their
traditions and their culture remain.
They don't fade away. I've been telling
you about Artsa because I really like
what they do. Especially when I see
entire nations doing the opposite. There
are Christian and Jewish small
businesses in Israel which take a hit
after every terror attack because
tourism plummets. Tens of thousands of
small businesses closed in 2024 because
there was almost no tourism. Artsa dealt
with the problem by gathering products
from local artisans in Jerusalem and
Nazareth and Bethlehem and other
locations and shipping them around the
world. We should respect and encourage
their resilience by signing up for a
quarterly arts box. They're not very
expensive, especially considering what
you're getting and how many people
you're helping. There's a link to the
arts website in the description box. Use
the promo code dizzle to get a discount
and to let them know who sent you. If
you'd like to watch the full
trigonometry video, that link is also in
the description box. Be sure to share it
so you can help other people confront
the civilization ruining challenges of
ignorance and weak leaders.
[Music]